my name is Mario Cesar Suarez I'm
working at the Mexican geothermal
Association and I am a member of the
International thermal Association
working on geothermal reservoir
engineering I'm going to present a
question of state of water the last
version programming in the mathematical
I work for the Mexican geothermal
association which is a branch of the
international geothermal association and
I'm very involved with on your thermal
reservoir engineering I'm going to
present you one of the most advances
equation of state for water the present
time well together with air water is the
most important substance existing on
earth for not only for living organism
but also in science and in many
industrial applications in computation
all three dynamics steam turbines in
high pressure devices and in super
critical systems the International
Association for the properties of water
and steam it's a International
Association formed by several national
committees in Europe United States
Australia Japan Russia and so on this is
the first version published in 1995 and
I'm going to present you the last
release of 2016 this formulation is a
worldwide accepted mathematical
formulation reproducing with maximum
accuracy millions of experimental data
obtain it since the time of Carnot up to
present time and this formulation is
presented here in the form of a
computable notebook in the world from
programming language of Mathematica
version 11 point 2 okay the water
properties in this formulation are
calculate calculated for single-phase
water and steam and as function of
density and absolute temperature and for
two-phase water liquid and steam
coexisting as a function of saturation
temperature pressure of saturation of
course all water properties are defined
in terms of the Helmholtz potential that
is a finite as energy internal energy of
the water
minus the product absolute temperature
by entropy and these are the definitions
of the every property important in water
this is pressure energy enthalpy entropy
is occurring specific heat isobaric
specific heat water compressibility
Joule Thomson coefficient
speed of sound and thermal expansivity
and as a result of this we can define
the thermal diffusivity of water the
units of this properties are indicated
here the Helmholtz free energy is in
kilojoules per kilogram density is in
kilograms per cubic meter temperature in
Kelvin pressure in mega Pascal's Intel
energy in kilojoules per kilogram
enthalpy kilojoules per kilogram entropy
kilo Joule per kilogram a psychotic heat
Joule per kilogram per Kelvin isobaric
heat the same compressibility the
inverse of Pascal Joule Co efficient is
key Kelvin divided by bar the speed of
sound in meters per second thermal
expansivity in inverse of Kelvin and
thermal diffusivity and square meters
per second a surface tension of water is
only needed for two-phase occur can only
be defined for two phase water well in
natural systems like aquifers hydro
carbon and geothermal systems in general
as well as in atmospheric asean
interactions water of course the most
important acting fluid in particular
water in geothermal reservoirs covers a
wide thermal dynamic range because a
temperature gradient between the core of
the earth and the surface produces a
continuous flow of natural heat with
different gradient of temperatures this
is different for shallow depths to
medium depth thousands of meters and
even to deeper depths thousands of
10,000 or more meters until the in
immense temperatures of molten rocks
that is around 800 degrees C or more
than 1000 degrees C the normal thermal
gradient on air is about 20 average 25
degree C per kilometer but in anomalous
thermal gradients like geysers or New
Zealand fields or Mexican fields the
average gradient is about 150 degree C
per kilometer and the wide range of
temperatures for geothermal purposes is
between 370
Griese up to 5,000 degrees see this is
the core temperature of the earth and
this depth go from 3 kilometers down to
6,000 kilometers that corresponds to the
center of the earth at the same time in
every normal Sun from the geothermal
point of view there is heat conduction
flow and convection at the same time and
this is illustrated in the figure to the
right therefore water can be found in
your thermal conditions at very very
very 8 varied temperatures and different
conditions well it's very important to
see how is this the molecular structure
of water because it's apparently a
common substance but we don't have
intuition for these high pressures and
high temperature conditions for your
thermal systems we only know water in
the shower or eyes or boiling coffee or
something like that right okay I just
want splain you briefly that the
molecule of water is composed by two
hydrogen atoms and one actually oxygen
atoms as everybody knows but this
molecule has a particularity that forms
the three atoms forms approximately
align an angle 104.5 degrees and the one
very important point is that H hydrogen
atom is in line between the oxygen atom
of its own molecule and the oxygen atom
of a different molecule in the
neighborhood so this is the figure is
straighten this structural molecular
structure of water and this means from a
molecular point of view that this
hydrogen bonds have extra attractive
energy giving to the molecule of water
extraordinary stability that explain
many of the initial properties of water
at different thermodynamic conditions
for example water has large heat of
vaporization it expands upon freezing it
has low thermal conductivity
liquid conditions but it has higher
specific heat that means it is a capable
of absorb and store a lot of energy a
lot of heat at the same time he has very
low liquid compressibility and at the
same time in the steam face has a very
high compressibility water is basic and
acid at the same time and it's index PK
indexes exactly the same 15 point 74 for
acid M for basic conditions at the same
time viruses in universal solvent and
water reaches its maximum density at 4
degrees C not at 0 but at 4 degree C and
below 4 degrees C water density declines
and that is why fortunately ice floats
on liquid liquid water I can show you
this graph a graphic showing this
particular notice this is a water
density at 1 bar pressure and you see
that exactly at 4 degrees C it attains
its maximum after this temperature the
density of water the clients as I said
before all this explained it by the
extraordinary stability of its molecular
ok now let's talk about the this
formulation it's called at 95 95 because
it was the first version of the
formulation and this fundamental
potential is the reduced specific
Helmholtz free energy that is define it
but as the energy of water internal
energy minus temperature multiplied by
entropy from this formulation and from
this free energy it can be reduce it
make it dimensionless just by dividing
but are the gas constant and the
absolute temperature and this is called
V phase function of Delta is the
dimensionless density and tau is the
inverse of the dimensionless temperature
they are defined below and this reduces
a specific Helmholtz free energy is
formed by two parts p 0 there is a ideal
part and fear is a residual part both
engines of the same variables this is
very important to take into account
because at the same time that make is
very powerful at the same time produces
some practical problems in a real
geothermal field as I will explain later
these are the definitions of the
dimensionless density is the normal
density divided by the critical density
the inverse of the temperature similar
and reduced pressure normal pressure
divided by the critical pressure the
finite here the the values are here
define it now if if I write these
formulations using the mathematical code
it looks like this just take into
account that they are very simple this
formulas were obtained it by
interpolation and very sophisticated
nonlinear least squares so the formula
the final formulas are not so difficult
I not not involve any kind of special
function there are just logarithms
Exponential's and polynomials that's all
all the N 0 and I see be it so they're
constants their coefficients
responsibles of the good approximation
of the interpolation after no linear
radial sorry least squares of course I
cannot include here the coefficients per
color too many but they are programmed
in a part besides these two definitions
of the main feature and fear parts of
the Hellmann's produces energy we need
the derivatives of these functions that
were also obtained in a coherent way by
interpolation and least squares formulas
and we need all these things and all
have you that you see here in the screen
is the formulation of the international
properties for water and steam
okay now I have to want to present you
the four phases of water in this
formulation including ice ice liquid
steam and supercritical conditions you
can see it in the figure the figure
shows here to the left is the solid
there are several sub regions including
I six etc included in the formulation I
don't use it I just you start from one
or ten degrees C the triple point of
water is included steam liquid and gas
solid liquid and gas or and to the up to
the left its liquid phase here this
curve is the two phase conditions where
temperature and pressure are not
independent but they depend each one of
each other that is called the saturation
conditions and the critical point of
water below this critical point to the
right and up to this point there are the
super t the supercritical face of water
let me tell you something about the
limits of the formulation for the for
density for pressure sorry it goes from
very low pressures so zero point one or
zero point zero one bar up to 10,000 bar
and for temperatures between zero
degrees C and 1000 degrees C but it can
be extrapolated up to 1 million bar and
almost 5000 degrees okay four thousand
Kelvin
these are the ranches that the water can
be calculated using this formulation but
they are not experimental ranch there
are only extra places and you will see
in some graphics later why it is it is
all like that okay these are the the
functions define it in terms now of the
Helmholtz potential and the its
respective derivatives
express your internal energy specific
enthalpy specific entropy isochoric heat
isobaric heat bulk modulus is isothermal
compressibility and thermal compulsivity
and
conductivity speed of sound then well
here I have to tell you that they're the
blue the blue lines mean the extended
version of this formulation that I I did
it myself just using the same formulas
the same derivatives to include this
properties of water
there's just analytical calculations and
obtain a closer formula for these
properties I have explained this thing
in in practical terms all functions and
derivatives are computed as functions of
Delta and tau density and inverse
temperature in this formulation but in
your thermal fields it's very difficult
if not impossible to measure the density
of water with a required accuracy
because this will measure so precise
that we need at least six figures of the
decimal point to compute whether sting
therefore we need to inverse the the
properties to calculate first density
and then with pressure and temperature
and then use it to compute the final
properties well it's very very very rare
or strange that the best thing to use
with this backward formulation is
newton-raphson classical technique I can
find nothing better than this one the
error here is almost zero very often up
to ten to the nine ten to the minus ten
and the convergence is attain it in two
or three iterations maximum this is the
formula of newton-raphson here in the
first formula in terms of the Yuppie WS
formulation and at the end I've obtained
an approximated pal with but very close
to the real value of the density and
then I can use it again into the
original formulation this all these
things were formulated and program it
within a module in a single cell
computable cell in Mathematica 11.2
using the world from language for to
test the
Vallot of this formulation I use it the
same conditions or sorry the same
conditions proposed by the Association
and are indicated here here okay if you
compare with the original documents you
will obtain you will see that this
values obtained it with mathematic are
exactly the same as the proposal figures
for for to verify the code
so therefore the code is verified and we
have a very nice formulation now let's
explain you briefly what is how it works
the code works with a main model I call
it a uh PWS 95 of course in terms of
density and temperature and inside it
becomes dimensionless by the definition
I explained it before and the general
program overview is as follows first I
need to approximate the density with an
all and more simple formulation it's
called the international formulation
1967 because what's the year of the
formulation and the model itself this is
the body of the main code then I define
both parts of the Helmholtz free energy
theorem fear and their derivatives the
computation of single-phase the
remaining properties and the computation
of to face terminal properties because
there they are doing differently and
final a display of results in tabular or
in graphical form okay we can have a
look at the code sorry but this in
Spanish because I speak Spanish source I
will will not have time to translate it
but just the first part is explaining
what happened some backgrounds some
reference and here this part this is for
the density the first part is for the
density of liquid and the second parts
for the density of steam to approximate
the density for the backward
formulation inversion now it starts here
the IP WS 2016 code the the constants or
the parameters will define it here and
here starts the definition of the a
ideal part of the
the Helmholtz free energy and its
derivatives
I want to go very fast derivatives and
then more coefficients more concept that
I need for to formulate the residual
part I need some auxiliary functions
inside the code and here are the more
derivatives and so on and he this is the
formulation of the residual part of the
helmers energy okay everything's don't
all the rest of the code is just to
compute things and their derivatives and
here is a computation of the analytical
formulas for the properties i i i said
before
and finally the presentation of results
there are several options i will show
you no options are our summary this is
to face conditions and this is the
several options and finally graphics
conditions or or tabular form okay let's
look at how it works
I need this cell to introduce a program
okay now let's say I am going to
calculate one state only this how many
states you want to compute one then I
have this properties of the program for
example display program capabilities is
option number -1 and it just gave me the
properties that the problem can
calculate and I explained it before I
can I can have the opportunity to
terminate here the problem or to or to
continue I continue and then for example
I'm going to present some graphics so I
say thermodynamic seven options 7 is
plot a given property in two dimensions
or three dimensions
what kind of graphic two-dimensional or
three-dimensional is just
two-dimensional and then which property
well choose one
pressure and which can liquid or vapor
is choose vapor and then for which
temperate let's say I don't know 95
that's all
finish or there's a problem here
I have graphic 2 G 2 is 4 2 dimensions G
trace for three dimension let's see
what's happened with a two dimensional
graphic sorry it didn't work okay let me
do it again I don't know what's happened
with the product I just tested before we
make a three-dimensional graphics one
again seven 3d and pressure again the
temperature can see for liquid let's say
95 okay now III oh my god something is
wrong sorry when I tested the problem
would work at fine okay let me show you
another thing let's compute now for
example three states three states and I
will show you how with the words with
backward liquid phase thermodynamics is
option number 3 ok 1 1 temperature 1 bar
this is a generated table then I really
don't know what's happened with
I will show you the previous graphics I
made for example this this table is for
liquid conditions and it's presented in
tabular form for all the conditions I I
said before this is liquid this is mix
it some bars up for liquid some parcel
for steam and these other tables are to
verify the properties the first table is
exactly with the density and temperature
conditions required by the Helmholtz
free energy and the second table is for
the bubble formulation inverse
formulation and you can see that very
there are very very small differences
between both tables for density and pore
pressure and for the rest of all the
other conditions this is for
supercritical region and steam you can
see that we can go from 100 degrees C
down to 4000 degrees C and 10000 bar and
all the conditions are here I just want
to show you one very important thing
concerning density of water if we are
talking about steam for example at these
conditions we have a very low density
its vapor steam 0.59 kilograms per cubic
meter okay we go down to 400 degree C
and 250 bar that we are on supercritical
conditions we see that we have 166
kilowatts per cubic meter so as long as
the energy of steam depends on its
density that means that when producing
electricity using steam in supercritical
conditions it's much more efficient and
has marked more heat available to
generate electricity
unfortunately the turbines to use
supercritical steam they are not ready
it's just a question of technology to
use it but this the normal geothermal
steam use it now is 4 for 250 300 degree
c grand 50 degree C and not more the
future for geothermal energy is in the
supercritical phase
the other table shows the same the
approximation I made with the fruit and
this is a very nice graphic because it
shows the whole thing the red ball is
the critical point this is a two-phase
region or this two very zone here to the
left is liquid and to the right is steam
and up to this ball is the supercritical
condition there a supercritical region
of course I have to cut this because it
stands very very far and this is only up
to a hundred degrees C I have more
what's happened in the supercritical
region this and I said maybe a vertical
is better you see after the critical
point the behavior of pressure as
function of enthalpy becomes almost
almost straight lines that is why it's
very good to extrapolate the formulation
for the supercritical region the
behavior is very simple more simple than
close to critical point other properties
are dynamic viscosity density of water
specific entropy and now the last this
is entropy again one important thing
concerning the powerful of this
formulation it's very good but it's not
perfect you can see in this graphic this
is a graphic show the dependence of
specific isobaric heat with temperature
and something strange happens around the
critical point okay
it behaves like the values are too high
if I compare with other pressures yes I
observe this after the critical point
the behavior becomes more stable and if
you see it in in three dimensions we can
calculate one of the formulas appearing
in the calculation of the specific heat
and of course look at here I have to
divide between 10 to the 15 to visualize
this behavior and if I reduce the range
of the same formula the same part of the
CP calculation I observe
I have two singularities and this and
this the the ratio is 1.9 2.1 very very
very small
it's a typical behavior of singularity
and this is a problem with a
mathematical formula but it cannot be
solved with just by arranging things no
they can the solution is experimental
solution this is the three-dimensional
graphics of the specific isobaric heat
so you can see that is a singularity
appearing around the critical point and
something similar happens with
isothermal compressibility well okay
that's all I just come to end my
conclusions the conclusions are ok thank
you very much